I don't understand your hesitation dr.
Clyburn if STAR Labs research on the
alien corpse is complete project Cadmus
is perfectly suited to house it until
it's ready for disposal it's fine here
Lex Corp just needs to get the payload
rocket ready so the government can get
this creature off planet before it lands
in the wrong hands you know I've been
exonerated yes you and your star
bureaucrats can't keep trying me for
crimes I've been cleared of you may have
been cleared Luthor but no one thinks
you're innocent as far as I'm concerned
Cadmus is a genetic pirate ship posing
as a research
[Music]
someone track it where's it going up up
and away
[Music]
no one's touched a thing I know I just
wanted to check in on him you know
there's still a lot of people missing
after the battle they're being found
every day
Clark will show up he's got the best
reason of all to return
[Music]
thanks cat Louis good you're still here
yeah what's going on please scanners
come on Jim I'm in no mood to chase the
story right now you will be trust me
you drive
[Music]
is it true you tell me
oh my god
[Music]
Superman
hey everybody its Charlie I got a lot of
requests to do a post-credits scene
video for the death of Superman this is
obviously setting up the reign of the
Superman so we'll just go through this
shot by shot most of you probably
remember a version of the death and
return of Superman arc in the comics and
you can kind of see how they're using
the animated movies to move through
those arcs so I don't know if we're
gonna see the return of Superman during
the reign of the Superman movie or if
return of Superman will be like the next
movie after the reign of the supermen
but if you're brand new to the channel
there's a new round of that flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video first big scene is Lex Luthor
arguing with STAR Labs saying that his
Cadmus labs should get possession of
Doomsday's body and Superman's
Kryptonian pod when all of a sudden it
just mysteriously takes off like the pod
just disappears then Jimmy comes running
into the Daily Planet telling Lois that
someone has stolen Superman's body from
the tomb where they just buried it a
little while ago then they see the
silhouette of what looks like Superman
flying in the distance but they can't
see his face so that is the Eradicator
the Eradicator steals Superman's body
and then I'll just jump through the
post-credits scenes because then we go
straight to Superboy's origin story in
the four different Superman so the first
one is Conner Kent Superboy escaping his
cryo tube at Cadmus labs
in taking off so you can see that
costume looks a little bit more like new
52 but if you're not a big comic book
reader the only real things that they've
changed about his origin story from the
comics is is that in the original story
Lex Luthor didn't have anything to do
with Cadmus labs so what happened is is
they wreck on that story a little bit
later and what happened was is Lex
Luthor found out about the project and
just spliced his DNA when they were
starting the cloning process so Conner
Kent became half Lex Luthor so that he
would later be able to mentally take
over his mind and turn him evil against
all the rest of the Justice League and
the Teen Titans in the movie version is
just Lex Luthor being in charge of
Cadmus labs secretly trying to clone
Superboy himself all this time that's
why he specifically named raw Cadmus
labs when he's arguing at the beginning
of this clip then you get the John Henry
irons scene is just him creating the
suit that he wears he calls himself
steel
we get the Eradicator scene so you see
the Eradicator rebuilding the fortress
of solitude and you see that he was the
one that programmed the pod to leave
STAR Labs because it comes lowering down
into frame here the whole reason he did
that is because he is an artificial
intelligence built to preserve
Kryptonian culture he was activated when
Superman died and created a body for
himself using some of Superman's DNA but
as a side effect got some of Superman's
memories so he's kind of confused about
who he is he remembers his life with
Lois but he doesn't have any of
Superman's compassion so he just winds
up being a super hardcore version of
Superman so the whole reason why he
steals Superman's body is one because
he's built to preserve Kryptonian
culture so anything Kryptonian the
Superman has spread out over the world
he collects that takes it back to the
fortress of solitude for safekeeping and
what happens is is he gets his powers by
siphoning yellow sunlight through
Superman's body so he has to put
Superman's body into a special chamber
the side effect of that is is that
Superman's body is literally absorbing
yellow sunlight slowly over the course
of the reign of the Superman arc until
his body's absorbed enough energy for
him to wake up and become conscious
again so that's all about the return of
Superman we might see that at the end of
this movie maybe like a post-credits
scene and they'll do another movie after
this but obviously the last scene is
cyborg superman flying in from deep
space the whole thing with him is that
he's another artificial intelligence
like he's a person that hated Superman
and became his enemy but his body was
destroyed in this big accident in outer
space
so his floating consciousness just sort
of grafted itself a body so he kind of
became this Terminator which is why he
has the metal parts of his body then
grabs himself a Superman endoskeleton
skin just like a terminator wood so
that's probably the easiest way to think
about him is this a terminator Superman
but he's totally lying about who he is
because he's fully conscious of what's
going on he wants to destroy the earth
but he doesn't have a lot of personal
knowledge of what happened with Lois
Lane recently like there was a romance
between the two of them he wouldn't have
any of that the really sly way that he
explains that is that he says oh you
know the reason why my body is half
metal is because it was destroyed in the
fight with doomsday in I
some of my memories which is why I can't
answer really specific questions that
only Superman and Lois Lane would know
so you can kind of understand why Lois
Lane gets really suspicious and starts
to figure out who he is before it's
almost too late but by that time
Superman's body is absorbed in a feel of
sunlight and he comes back there's no
actual specific release date for rain of
Superman they just say 2019 but I have a
feeling that it'll be around comic-con
next year just like their release death
of Superman around Comic Con this summer
so spring summer next year but what'll
happen is is I'll name a giveaway winner
when I post a new DC click here for the
official trailer for reign of the
Superman and click here for that brand
new flash trailer with the official
costume reveal thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]